hey theo how you doing this is ali out
in dubai
i hope you're doing it what's up ali in
dubai my brother and i'm
envious of you and take care of uh
michael chandler and dustin poirier when
they're
over there and take care of dan hooker
and conor mcgregor
and take care of all them boys and over
there knuckle tussling man gang praise
god brother onward
well i wanted to get your thoughts on
hamster healthcare
uh you're the resident hamster expert as
we all know
and i wanted to give you a quick uh call
to
get your thoughts about how we should be
treating hamsters when they're sick
so amen brother and um
this ought to be interesting let's go
brother homeward long story short
my wife bought my kids a couple of dwarf
hamsters about a year ago so
okay yeah and that's roborovskies man
dwarf hamsters are roborovskies and
they're small and they're real cute
they look uh almost like somebody just
you know
tickled a uh marshmallow and put eyes in
it onward
they're like hamsters but smaller uh
hence the name dwarf
and one of them got sick a couple weeks
ago a few weeks
ago his eyes swelled up and my kid
thought he was blind in one eye and i
said okay just give him a patch
uh give him a little cane he'll be okay
or send them outside and let the
neighborhood cats have their way and let
nature take its course
but my wife thought no we gotta take him
to the vet so
we got into a little bit and then she
took him to the vet
the vet hit us with some uh dwarf
hamster healthcare which cost me about a
hundred dollars
yeah well look and ollie and i and i
love it and
uh and i'm glad y'all out there loving
animals and loving the essays baby them
small animals
you know when they had a guy used to
live by me his boy named chucky and he
used to
you know he'd smoke cigarettes and
you know he used to [ __ ] supposed to
be putting the shopping carts away at
dell champs and he damn lied
and he was doing drugs but um
uh what i'm telling you look
a hamster is not a vettable animal
you know a hamster that's a damn look
it's not i mean it's i mean it's
that's a you know a ham a hamster is not
a vettable animal brother it's a
that's a to-go lunch for a wolf
you know i really think you should just
let the lord work on him there brother
uh he took his blood pressure he checked
his heart rate this kind of stuff a
little bit strange to me
any case they also hit him with some
antibiotics so we were giving him
antibiotics for a couple weeks
and then uh he died he had they didn't
work
and so now we buried him in the backyard
god is the number one veterinarian
okay god is the number one veterinarian
especially
for a hamster okay your hamster got to
cataract
that means it's looking for the lord
baby
your pony needs a hip replacement that
don't mean
spend 20 dollars to get little daisy a
new piss hinge okay
let the lord work that means the lord
got his
tool belt on and he's ready to go
your frog has a lisp that'll mean it
needs a
speech therapy it needs a grave
a grave is the lord's lost and found let
the lord
collect them and refurb them you feel me
your hyena needs a chin bone well let
the lord
your kitten got a cleft palate well
let the lord your guinea pig
got a arthritis well ltl baby
let the lord y'all out here
tinkering with the man's work somebody
out in beverly hills got a
pet mosquito in a back brace [ __ ]
let the lord you trying to teach a
turtle spanish
uh le el
you all need to quit acting like god
don't do the work
and
okay that's what i'm telling you right
there baby
and thank you for calling ali man you
got to be good over there brother gang
i'm just sitting on your front porch
wondering how could i be so
far from my home
and my mind is somewhere else but when i
find it i'll patch up where it's been